l'histoire des charts tyler est
semblable à celle de nombreux autres
restaurateurs difficultés à
s'approvisionner et à trouver des
employés entre pandémie et pénurie les
épreuves sont nombreuses
mais
rose tyler envisage même suivre
l'exemple d'autres établissements et
réduire ses heures d'ouverture les
restaurants londoniens dépendent
beaucoup d'employés venus du continent
dont la présence se fait rare depuis que
le royaume uni a quitté l'union
européenne
il accuse le gouvernement de boris
johnson d'ignorer cette réalité si
londres a annoncé l'octroi de visas
temporaires aux camionneurs notamment
pour alimenter les stations-services
aucun accommodement n'a encore été prévu
pour aider le secteur de la restauration
l'opposition travailliste accusé le
gouvernement conservateur d'avoir mal
planifié la sortie de l'union européenne
devant ses militants réunis en congrès
le premier ministre a tenté de minimiser
l'importance des impacts du brics it
industry
and control et migrations oim et lui dit
voilà c'est un objet qui voulut de
briques site contrôler les frontières
pour que les européens ne viennent plus
et donc les salaires et augmente puisque
pénurie de main d'oeuvre est donc obligé
en fait les les entreprises à augmenter
les salaires selon ce journaliste auteur
d'une biographie de boris johnson le
premier ministre al avantage de faire
face à une opposition qui a de la
difficulté à s'imposer et la stratégie
exposée ces derniers jours demeure un
pari risqué mais j'ai rencontré beaucoup
de députés pendant le congrès qui m'ont
expliqué il nous faut absolument des
preuves concrètes que le pays est en
train de changer charles taylor ne
s'attend pas à une sortie de crise
rapide en plus des enjeux de main
d'oeuvre il a vu sa facture
d'électricité doublé comme d'autres pays
d'europe le royaume uni est confronté à
une hausse des tarifs de l'énergie selon
lui les consommateurs en paieront le
prix
les prochaines élections britanniques
n'ont lieu qu'en mai 2024 c'est à ce
moment que l'on pourra juger si la
gestion du mexique aura des
répercussions politiques sur le
gouvernement en place et ce huit ans
après la tenue du vote pour quitter
l'union européenne ici rappelle movie
auclair radio canada à londres